hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be taking a look at a
pretty commonly requested video about
the samsung galaxy s3 i've reviewed the
samsung galaxy s3 already and part of
the thing that i talked a lot about was
touchwiz which was on top of it and
touchwiz is the skin on top of android
4.0 on the galaxy s3 when you get it
it's planned to have an upgrade to
touchwiz the next version which will be
on top of android 4.1 but i've enjoyed
my galaxy nexus so much that i wanted a
pure almost near stock android
experience on my galaxy s3 so without
any further ado i'm gonna be taking a
look at my favorite rom so far for the
galaxy s3 if you've read it you can get
cyanage mod 10 where the nightly builds
and i'll show you what it looks like
running on my verizon galaxy s3 let's go
ahead and take a look by the way i have
no idea if this is the final angle for
what i'm going to be doing videos at i'm
still sort of messing around with things
getting it set up but uh let's get into
this real quick now the first thing
you'll notice about your device when you
turn it on is your lock screen and
that's because the lock screen here i
have it right next to the galaxy nexus
here this is running pure stock android
4.1 and this is running cyan engine mod
and you can see here that the lock
screen is identical i could add some
other shortcuts up here and up here if i
wanted to but you also have to swipe up
google now left for camera and right to
unlock and that is where you'll get to
your home screen and that's where the
the similarities are pretty much the
same for the rest of everything else
with some minor additions thanks to
cyanogenmod so first of all to make sure
you have android 4.1 jelly bean you can
go to menu and system settings and at
the bottom there's about phone and you
can see here android version 4.1.1 and
cyanogenmod is the kernel version and we
have of course our full two gigs of ram
you'll actually find that you use less
ram because touchwiz does use a little
bit of the ram and you won't have any of
that ram being used by touchwiz when
you're running stock android some other
neat additions are you get to swipe down
from the notification bar and you'll get
your toggles here from cyanogenmod so
wi-fi toggle bluetooth your gps and you
can change your volume and set it to
volume on or vibrate or silent or
whatever you want to do there also
project butter is present throughout the
operating system so everything is just
dead smooth there's no hiccups or
stuttering as far as i've seen uh just
like android 4.1 on other devices that
are running stock android there aren't
many but you can get that experience by
running cyanogenmod and it is absolutely
buttery smooth google now still works so
i'll ask it a random question like uh
what's the weather like
what is the weather like
and it'll go ahead and tell me what the
weather's like here and if you have the
volume on it'll go ahead and read stuff
out google now works flawlessly data
works flawlessly there is nothing
missing or wrong or incorrect about this
rom and that's why it's been working
perfectly as a daily driver for me also
i'll show you the camera this is another
big reason that i've been using the
galaxy s3 is because that 8 megapixel
camera but it still has instant shutter
so of course if we take a picture here
it'll move to the side and it's
instantly available and you can swipe
left and right and go through the
pictures you've taken all that software
still works this will take panorama and
you can now take 1080p video and just
keep taking really really fast shutters
and eight megapixel photos will just fly
through like that also for location
aware apps like say google maps the
galaxy s3 actually has some of the
fastest gps lock of any device i have
ever used so if you ever have any issues
with that well you won't have any issues
with that google maps navigation uh any
gps tagging stuff like foursquare
that'll all work perfectly quickly and
really really fast thanks to the fast os
and the fast gps lock on this phone some
other neat things so you notice there
are no software buttons on the bottom so
i'll bring in the nexus again so you can
see there are these software buttons
back multitasking and home uh but you
don't have these here on the galaxy s3
because you have your home button here
you have your menu button and you have
your back button and those all still
work perfectly in terms of battery life
i've gotten some pretty decent battery
life i do use my phone quite a bit you
can see here it's been on for six hours
with quite a bit of screen on time
actually not a lot of screen on time but
quite a bit of usage basically and it's
halfway through the day and i have 76
battery life left i typically end the
day around 11 p.m and i'll have about 20
left which is pretty good but besides
that everything else about the phone is
fast i mean i haven't gotten a lot of
questions about it but basically uh
people wanted to know is it daily driver
material and from what i got to say from
my experience yes this is daily driver
material so i can use this for all my
apps that are compatible with android
4.1 and below you know twitter apps
notifications all that kind of stuff it
just works i haven't found any flaws
with it and it's been a really enjoyable
experience so far so connects to really
fast data i'll go ahead and do a speed
test here just because i happen to feel
like showing off my new wi-fi but i mean
there's not a whole lot that goes wrong
at all i haven't had any random reboots
this happens to be the verizon version
of the samsung galaxy s3 which means
you'll have to get past the bootloader
before you do any of your routing and
flashing your rom so i'll have
instructions for that below but
basically
if you have any questions feel free to
send me a message on youtube or go ahead
and leave a comment below and i'll do my
best to help you out this is an
absolutely highly recommended rom i just
there's nothing wrong with it at all and
uh it's a pleasurable experience here's
a quick tip i use on all the 4.x devices
if you go to settings and you go down
past all that cyanogenmod and google
stuff and you go to developer options
you can go down here into your
animations and change the animation
scale to 0.5 x so let's say you want to
make it really really slow by 5x you'll
see all the animations are really really
slowed down by default it's actually 1x
if you make it 0.5x you'll notice your
device just feels a lot snappier and you
can turn animations off completely
but i prefer to have them on really
snappy and it feels really really fast
and last thing you should know is there
are some cyanogenmod settings in here so
if you go to interface you can change
some settings about the launcher so you
can change your look and feel
you can change all the different
cyanogenmod settings if you have themes
if you have profiles all the stuff is
accessible in here so if you're a really
hardcore android person you can go in
and customize and change everything
about this stuff you can change which
buttons you have up here in the widgets
uh you can change which toggles you have
all that stuff is available to you and
uh that's pretty sweet so i've been
using cyanogenmod 10 for android 4.1.1
and i love it so there you go it's
really really close to stock android and
it has been my daily driver for a couple
of months now actually it's a really
really solid rom and i'd recommend it if
you've rooted your galaxy s3 for those
of you who are new to the whole flashing
a rom process and being rooted i'll have
some links below this video where you
can check out the best way to get your
phone rooted to get your bootloader
unlocked and to flash whatever rhyme you
want thanks for watching this video go
ahead and give a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it or if it was helpful at all
and uh next video is one that will be
that's been requested a lot more than
this particular video was so i hope you
guys are ready for that either way
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys later
peace
you